important though to have room in your
heart for new friends
and our next guest is a perfect example
of that one of my newer friends in life
james davis we became friends on the
show mostly football we survived our
football season working with martellus
bennett now he's hosting golf road
tripping one of the funniest dudes i
know i consider him a friend thanks for
joining the show man are you on the golf
course right now we get you on the turn
nah not today today's a day off i had to
actually be productive and like earn
some money
well i appreciate you taking some time
golf road tripping is one of the ways
you're earning money these days you got
a chance to play golf and get paid are
you a professional golfer now james
i'm a professional golf influencer uh
that's how i feel now like i feel like i
should be able to you know just show up
to golf courses and i get that i get
that hookup like honestly i feel like
they should let me play for free
the fact that you you've bamboozled the
system and worked it out for yourself to
get these uh opportunities to play golf
and get paid for it it's pretty
impressive man talk to me about your
love of golf and what you're doing on
this show
i mean well i mean that's one of the
first things i feel like we really
bonded on i feel like golf is like a
fraternity of people who are just
addicted to this sport that you know is
the most frustrating enjoyable
disgusting sport there is but i mean
i've been playing golf since high school
it's like my passion and i really showed
up during pandemic to shoot a sketch for
another show they had on this golf fast
network
and
the network was so new they wanted new
material and they loved me so much in
this one sketch that might by the way i
thought i did okay with you know i was
like you know this wasn't like my like
you know house party or my friday movie
but they loved me so much and they were
like you went to a travel show and i was
like uh yeah you want me to travel to
golf courses and you pay me
thousands of dollars to play golf yeah
i'll i'll be there for sure
the show is golf road trip and james
davis joins the rich eisen show ben
lyons in for rich i i speak
affectionately often james about our
season on mostly football and as we
embark on another nfl season has your
perspective on football changed having
been around martellus bennett as
intimately as we were
yes and no i feel like
my perspective on football changed
because i think i'm just more into it
because i was forced to really
pay attention to football during that
time we did that show but martellus is
like the most unique original dude ever
and i would never look at martellus and
be like
he's some example of a larger group of
people you know like like martellus is
martellus and i don't feel like there's
a lot of dudes in the nfl who are are
like him but i mean that's a that's a
that's a dope
very
complex
fun individual and i think the fact that
he was he's so creative that he can be a
host of a show like that but at the same
time he was so fresh and kind of like
new to it which brought something to the
show but i think it was very
entertaining for us as people who are a
little bit more seasoned in the hosting
space to see him be so
you know
adjacent to the normal formula of what
hosting is and i think i think honestly
just making eye contact with you during
parts of the show it was the best part
of the show for me well you would look
across the studio after martella said
something and you and i would lock eyes
and be like it might all be over but it
was fun while it lasted right like the
editors are gonna have their challenges
for this one
james davis joins the show golf road
trip informally of mostly football you
can catch him on a t-box near you james
you're one of those guys who just has
popped up in a lot of different things
over the years it's almost like carmelo
you forget which jersey he's worn he's
been on so many teams now
i saw you pop up in this old captain
planet skit with don cheadle that was a
ridiculous one
yo that was honestly one of that's one
of my crowning moments in entertainment
i mean that was during the time when
funny or die was really hot like will
ferrell and big a-list people were just
doing videos and i had done my baracka
flocka my kobe videos and i had a great
relationship with funny or die and they
were like he wanted this captain planet
video and i was like absolutely like i
loved captain planet and like for me to
be kwami and the captain planet sketch
was like
incredible i mean
to me i felt like i was in the captain
playing a movie once you get don cheadle
in a sketch with you you're like oh this
is the most legit sketch i've ever done
in my life for those looking for a laugh
this weekend just google don cheadle
captain planet you won't be sorry and
what i love about your career as well
james you've crossed paths with our own
t.j jefferson
yeah james what up man
uh bro hey you i don't know if you
remember this but a few years back i
used to be the comedy producer for this
little mtv show called yo mama it was
the one with the guy with the fingerless
gloves
you know
so i can remember
i remember this guy james davis who i
worked with i'm sure you don't remember
me but i i remember you and it's been
really dope kind of seeing how you've
grown and moved on past your mama and i
just wanted to know do you have any
memories do you remember uh being on
your mama it was a lot of projects to go
for you man i definitely do remember
being on your mom i remember the
audition because i went with my friend
and then we had to roast each other and
i'm really not a roast like yo mama type
of person like my company's very like
kind of positive so like the roast my
friend was a little uncomfortable and
then you know i got the show and he
didn't
and then yeah i remember writing my yo
mama jokes for this dude it was george
george the comedian from like he's like
a comedian right now
george perez yes
and like he and he beat me and i was
like damn you know like i it hurt it
hurt that he beat me but
you know honestly it was just those
moments of just being in front of the
camera that just make you want to keep
on doing it i mean i definitely don't
bring up your mama when people ask about
my biography of you know how i got into
the game and that hurts and that hurts
but you know what
it just shows the growth and like hey
i'm still doing mtv shows now so
that but that was a fun that was like my
earliest i think tv appearance
james davis joining the show golf road
tripping formerly of yo mama mostly
football
writing on bad boys three all types of
wild stuff over the years for james uh
let's get back to the game of golf
uh you play all over southern california
you play all over the country on this
show golf road tripping uh have you
connected deeper to the game what is it
that you love about golf it's the only
sport i think you can get better as you
get older
exactly exactly i mean first and
foremost me and you have to get out asap
now it's gonna be way way way too long
but
but to answer your question i mean i
feel like a professional
non-competitive golfer now like now that
i've actually been paid to
do golf things
it's
it's added to my delusion of golf where
now when i go to the driving range and i
hit balls or i took a golf lesson i'm
like yeah i got to do this man this is
for work you know i might have to show
up and shoot an episode and i can't be
playing bad golf so it's like in my mind
now golf is a part of how i i earned my
money you know i'm closer to what it
feels like to be a professional golfer
but also i just i love the game of golf
and i think at times when you're doing
so many other things and especially for
me like you said i'm all over from
writing to stand up to acting and
there's a lot of other parts of life
that i tap into but if i'm honest with
myself i just really love golf and to be
able to explore golf for myself and know
that i'm also
adding to my wheelhouse of what i can do
as far as golf entertainment the fact
that entertainment and golf are now like
kind of married in my life is like this
just perfect almost like spiritual like
i feel blessed like god knows i love
golf and he knows i love making people
laugh and doing entertainment and he's
put it together so like what more can i
ask for but like a billion dollars
and now god has brought carmelo anthony
to southern california to pursue a
championship alongside lebron james you
know me i'm a die-hard purple and gold
laker lifer oh boy you know that about
me james i live and die with these
lakers my whole life i was there at the
forum welcome welcome carmelo anthony
part of the lakers you think he'll pick
up golf here in southern california or
he's going to be out smoking cigars at
tarania
you know he he just might la the
hollywood life he might have one or two
meetings you know i know dwayne wade's
playing golf now like drake just posted
his golf clubs literally yesterday so
like golf is growing like i don't really
see carmelo as a golfer but i could see
him out there maybe you know playing a
couple rounds here and there like you
said at the at the higher echelon
courses just for some recreation but
i don't know if me and him are going to
be out there maybe you know that i mean
that's what's great about golf right now
and especially a show like my show is
that i want to show people like that
playing golf and not just the
stereotypical
country club
scratch golfers that you already expect
to see
you know us laker fans we missed out on
a championship parade we didn't get that
parade because the way the world but now
things opening back up so when mello
wins a title are you going to be at the
parade that'll be for both titles right
this this spring
yeah the goal is to hustle real hard get
my name up in these streets get about
three million more followers so by the
time that that parade comes around and
they need to host mc
i'm the guy because i don't want to see
some old
50 year old i don't know some cedric the
entertainer or some even a kevin hart or
somebody who's not a laker fan like you
need a die hard
comedian celebrity who is a laker fan
like anthony anderson clipper fan like i
don't want to see him like i am i want
to be the news i want to be the spike
lee of the lakers and like i want to i
want to get my name up so that by the
time that parade comes around which it
will i agree
they need to call your boy
the show is golf road tripping james
davis i will hope to see you on a golf
course soon my friend thanks for taking
some time
hey i appreciate it man i'm i'm gonna do
it i'm gonna go on the site right now
and just look up some tea times and text
you i'm gonna i'm gonna put the first
step
james davis joining the show james do it
man hey ben before james goes do you
think james could hit us with a yo mama
joke before he leaves
family show
wow okay honestly
[Laughter]
let me put you on the spot
yeah i by the way all your mama jokes
are old and you've already heard them so
don't be like oh i've heard this one
already okay
anyway yo mama's so dumb i told her i
went to the super bowl
and the girl brought some chili
james davis golf road tripping thanks
for taking some time hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here